right you don't give me that respect
captain I know but that's not hyung so I
start saying young yeah I say you like
my gay friend you always like hey like
what I'm driving by you when you I saw
your sister in you yeah on 6th Street
that one day yeah you get in then I roll
down the window you talk to me like
you're you're my gay friend Yeah right
and I want I know I went young some more
fear not fear respect yeah you don't
respect me I respect you so much I don't
think you do I do
okay you guys film crazy rich Asians in
congratulations graduates the big movie
gets Singapore Malaysia that was an
amazing experience we had a we had
Aquafina here too you know I was just
saying with her last Friday she's the
reason why I do Jules because she gave
me her jewel because I was smoking
cigarettes uh-huh and she goes hey young
she could smoke these and she gave me
her jewel and I quit smoking because oh
that's great she is awesome I feel like
she's so funny if she wasn't a rapper
she'll be like one of the best stand-up
comedians oh she could do it I love
Instagram story her just commentary on
anything
yeah is just on point she's so quick she
got it yeah you know she what does that
movie come out August 17th Oh awesome
it's great I mean it was such an
experience cuz I think most of us were
kind of you know the Asian community we
have which someone have a community like
of course I know you I know ken even
before I actually knew you guys yeah we
just kind of keep track on each other
we're kind of proud of each other you
know but it was like doing this movie in
a foreign country or in Singapore and
all of us are like you got the most
beautiful funniest most talented best
actor of all Asia people you just like
holy [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] proud to be Asian
man who everyone oh you wanna be named
name some who are whose little name drop
it so Henry Golding is his lead
Constance was two female yes Michelle
Yeoh the legend
Harry Shum Jr I did movie with Michelle
yeah oh really
she's great which movie that's called
final recipe hmm it's an iTunes
if I don't I didn't yeah and I don't
like the way you said that because you
thought I was lying no I was just asking
I was curious I was trying to give you
an some residual shitty movie I never
plug the movie she's amazing in her
final recipe
she's final recipe and then you got you
got literally Asian Australians Asian
Americans you know how even there all
the tiny is alright pretty much most of
Nico Santos is in it useful you know and
John Campinas half Ken Jong is for
Korean yeah I know
yeah how long were you guys out there
for I think total shoot was maybe a
month and a half two months I was
different like a month on an audition
they offered no they wanted me to
audition and he got hurt that they
wanted to audition
what do you mean I think Betty well I I
just want to say this right I got it
networks you know show coming out and
just let me hear me out have a network
show coming out with Jenna Fischer on
offer okay
you think Kendra I will they can run now
that was an offer that was offering yeah
I think so okay yeah oh okay gotcha okay
it's fine I don't care I care about that
you care about that
anyway um final recipe I - final recipe
show that did you know I did but you
know so they you know it's fine but
Malaysia Singapore Singapore is an
interesting country it's great do they
keep put you in nice hotels yeah I mean
there's is so fun that's the thing I
should have realized about which part I
don't remember but I read you know you
know what it is let me tell you
something when I when I got the script
when I well first of all well when when
I heard the movie is coming out I didn't
read the book yet and I called my agents
I'm like dude I'm I'm a pretty good
agent coming up in Hollywood
like this is an all-asian movie let me
let me at least try to read the lead
part I don't know if I'm right for it
let me call in see if I can try to read
for the lead part yeah then my manager
is like look you're looking for like a
good-looking guy really your type yeah
so I'm like you know what say no more
I'll play whichever character right but
but but even when Brian washed my agent
oh no not the same agent Brian didn't
say that my manage instance but they're
very honest like they didn't like that's
not my that's why they should be yeah
yeah did they want it like the leading
man like Henry Golding you know and but
anyways to like for your point is when I
was reading the script were like I don't
have to audition to and and you know and
everything but um it was like oh man
it's an all-asian movie in Hollywood and
I'm probably one of the top Asians in
Hollywood I had the same thought I'm
like they should just give an offer to
me and I went and I was hung over when I
went into that audition yeah cuz I
didn't care that much but sometimes when
you hang over you don't care yeah
actually it's the best yeah but then
when I went there to actual shoot I'm
like holy [ __ ] this is a [ __ ]
life-changing experience and if the
audience feel a bit of Pride and magic
that I felt on this set this movie's
gonna be a hit I'm sorry I'm not trying
to give you FOMO that's I need a second
a second I made a mistake
well if it does well we live a second a
third what if it doesn't I'm gonna laugh
Ryan you're [ __ ] I'm gonna laugh
right in your [ __ ] face that's young
[Music]